So, this is kind of part of your core philosophy, right?
Like breaking things down into the sort of smallest
components so that you can digest them one by one.
I think it's essential, Rich, for me in my life,
yeah, it's breaking, not only breaking,
say a race, breaking it down from a tree to tree
or rock to rock perspective,
but even breaking down the outcomes.
When I go and race, I never feel any pressure
and I never really get nervous, man,
because in my mind I've broken that race down
into two outcomes.
I'm either going to break my body
or I'm going to achieve victory or cross the finish line.
That simplifies it so much for me.
And is that philosophy advisable?
Well, I don't know.
I think that's a choice for every individual to make,
but for me I look at these races as missions,
almost like missions in my life and I'm willing to accept
the fact that I could potentially break myself
to accomplish this mission.
Right.
Well, the other option is to quit.
The other option is to quit.
Yeah, but you just don't put that on the table.
I don't put it on the table, man.
And by no means am I trying to sound super tough
or I subscribe to this saying,
it's, "Be hard when it gets hard."
And at Ultra it gets hard.
So that's when I liked hunker down.
Yeah, there's this ethos out there.
I saw you kind of speaking about this on Instagram
out there, like stay hard you gotta be hard 24/7.
And I think people in general need a kick in the pants.
And that's a worthy message that I think is helpful
to a lot of people who've gotten a little too cushy
or comfortable in their lives.
But staying hard all the time
is not a sustainable lifestyle philosophy, is it?
It's not sustainable, Rich.
And I really feel like for me personally,
it's a dangerous philosophy
because if you think as a man or a woman
that you have to be hard all the time,
we said it's not sustainable.
So you're gonna fall short of that mark.
And when you fall short of that mark,
you're gonna beat yourself up about it.
And it just causes problems,
I feel like for me personally.
And it causes problems in relationships, man.
When I was active duty, I could be out on the road
or be on deployment.
Well, when you come back, you gotta be able
to love your family and love the other people around you
and show compassion and emotion.
And those aren't components of being hard all the time,
they're components that are necessary
to living a healthy lifestyle.
What's the point otherwise, right.
But they're not teaching that to you in BUD/S.
No, that's something that I had to learn.
Yeah, I mean, they turn you into this,
I don't wanna say monster, but they turn you
into what I guess society would call an alpha male in BUD/S.
Yeah, right.
So stay hard when it's appropriate to be hard,
when you need to be hard.
Have a place inside of you that you can go to
when it gets hard and you can get the job done.
It's all right.
So you're in BUD/S, is it what you thought it would be,
expected it to be,
harder, easier.
I would say seal training is probably like the one thing
in life that surpassed its reputation.
In terms of difficulty.
Intensity.
For sure.
And there again, I'm talking about the whole picture
right now.
What is the main thing that you take away
from that experience?
There's so many things that we could talk about
that were born in that experience.
I'd say the one thing that I utilize the most
right now is the lessons that we learned
that revolve around, I call it the power of the spoken word.
The things that we say, how the things that we say
impact our direction in life
and the outcome of our situations.
And one of the earliest times I'll remember
seeing this work was in first phase,
my best friend came to me one day and he said,
"Chad, I don't think I'm good enough
"to make it through this training anymore."
And I had known prior to that statement
that he had been having some thoughts of doubt,
but when he kept those thoughts within his own head,
he was able to continue from day to day.
But as soon as he came to me that morning
and spoke it out loud, that statement,
he created that re reality.
It became real.
It crushed him, man.
He was crushed by that single statement,
I don't think I'm good enough.
And shortly after he made that statement,
he went and quit.
And I thought, this guy, my buddy,
he was completely physically capable
of doing everything that we had to do that day
and every single day until graduation.
But those words crushed him, man.
It was like the Rubicon.
Once he crossed that, there's no return.
Once you give voice to whatever it is,
whatever demon is swimming around in your head,
it gives it a power that you can't take back.
There's something about the spoken word, man.
And I think the written word has similar and equal power,
but a lot of my stuff,
lessons revolve around that spoken word
and now that's transferred,
that lesson has transferred into ultra running.
And I've seen that power of the spoken word
push people beyond their conceived limits.
So, what do you make of that?
Like what is that about?
Like, how is it that the spoken word
can carry that kind of power.
For me, a thought that's in your head,
it's just a thought,
it's not tangible to anyone else except for you.
But when you speak something out loud,
it actually becomes something real,
something that can be measured.
So it becomes something that's part of this reality
that we live in.
And I feel like that's what gives it
the power of the spoken word.
I feel like that's why it's so powerful
because as a thought, it's essentially
it's not part of this reality that we're living in,
but as soon as you speak it, it becomes real.
That's where I find the power at man.
Cool.
All right, well, let's end this with a final thought
for the person who's out there who feels stuck.
They're in a rut.
Maybe they're not happy with their job
or they're trying to get off the couch
and move their body for the first time in a long time.
Like, how do we cattle prod that dude
or that young lady to get after it a little bit more.
Come on, man.
oh my God.
Bring us home.
Rich, man, I am not much of a...
I may hire you as my life coach, come on man.
I am not much of a cattle prod.
That's the thing, Rich.
I mean, like I say, I'm so hesitant to give advice
or to try to tell someone what to do.
I mean, I guess I could just keep it super simple
and go over the things we talked about,
simplify things, don't be afraid to put yourself
in adverse situations
because that's where you're going to grow as a human being.
The decisions you make in times of adversity,
self inflicted or totally out of your control
are the things that diff...
Those decisions define who you are as a human,
but don't fear inflicting that adversity on yourself
because that's going to help you grow as a human being.
So I would say, go put yourself through a little adversity.
It may be only running for five minutes to start with.
It may not be running, it may be something
completely different than that.
But don't fear it because I feel like it's essential
for us as humans to experience that in life.
And the last thing that I would say
is if you're struggling emotionally
from that kind of aspect is, take a look at your body,
soul and spirit.
Look at those three aspects of your humanity
each as a single lane and think about what are you doing
on a day-to-day basis to master nourish
and maintain your body, your soul and spirit.
And usually that can be used as a diagnostic
to see, okay I am lacking here, I'm lacking
and I need to get some help with my emotional side.
My will, what I want and don't want to do.
Do I wanna get out of bed in the morning,
do I not wanna get out of it?
That type of stuff.
And then the spiritual side,
that can be, it doesn't matter what it is.
It could be spending time in nature.
For me, it's spending time in God's word.
It could be anything.
Well, a lot of people's new year's resolutions
pivot around movement.
And that's what you're writing about in this new book.
So let's talk about movement.
I'm super interested in hearing your thoughts
that you explore in this book about
what's happening with us psychologically
and biochemically when we move our body.
oh, let's start with the biochemical
'cause some of this is so fascinating.
Can I explain the whole molecule thing?
Yeah, oh, trust me, I wrote that down.
Like these hormones, recent, the myokines.
Isn't that amazing.
This is super interesting.
I know when I found...
So I came across this paper,
I think it was maybe a 2016 paper
where the scientists talk about this research
and they just sort of throw out the term hope molecules.
And I remember circling it.
I think I said to my husband,
"oh my gosh you're not gonna believe this term."
It encapsulates so much about why movement is amazing.
And I feel like nobody else is using this term,
it was just this one paper.
I'm gonna ensure the scientists have used it again,
but let me explain what it is.
So this is the idea that our muscles
are like an endocrine organ.
And that when you contract your muscles
in any type of movement, they are secreted chemicals
into your bloodstream
that are really good for every system of your body.
I mean, they're great for your heart health
and your immune function.
And some of them can kill cancer cells.
All the stuff we know exercise is good for.
But that a big part of these proteins,
the chemicals that are being released by your muscles
which are called myokines,
they have profound effects on the brain.
So you go for a walk or a run or you lift weights
and your muscles contract and they secrete these proteins
into your bloodstream, they travel to your brain,
they cross the blood brain barrier.
And in your brain, they can act as an antidepressant
like (indistinct).
They can make your brain more resilient to stress.
They increase motivation,
they help you learn from experience.
And the only way you get these chemicals
is by using your muscles.
It's like, this is part of how we become our best selves,
is we have to use our muscles.
And then the scientists called them hope molecules
because in this one study
they found that exercise could protect rodents
from experiencing depression
and post-traumatic stress disorder
if you severely traumatize them.
So this idea that these molecules are giving you hope
even in very difficult times.
So it's not innately human, there's existence of it--
That's right, it's not innately humans.
It is in other mammals.
So I don't know how many species this has been studied in.
It's like in this field,
you tend to go from mice and rats to humans.
There's like not a lot in the middle,
but it should be pointed out
that rodents are very social species.
And that's one of the reasons
why they can be really great models for human behavior
'cause they look a lot like us
in some of the very basic social and psychological ways.
So extrapolating on that idea,
what do you make of that?
Like, what does that mean?
Well, first of all, a very practical level,
it means when I go for a walk or I exercise,
I will literally say to myself,
you are giving yourself an intravenous dose of hope.
I think this is how we should frame movement.
That it's something you can choose to do
to really powerfully influence your mental health
and your resilience.
And every time you move, you're doing that.
I think to know that, to look at your own muscles
and be able to say, thank you legs,
you're tired now.
That was hard work, but like, legs, you are a pharmacy
of antidepressants and resilience and hope.
Then sort of thinking in a more philosophical way.
Again, one of the things that I feel like the anthropology
and the science is pointing to
is that movement is how your brain knows you are alive
and engaged in life.
And when you move on a regular basis,
your brain basically says,
I guess we have to be the best version of ourselves
because we're in this thing called life.
And so, you mentioned some other things too.
Like when you exercise, you see increased levels
of neurotransmitters that tend to increase
our willingness to cooperate.
And the pleasure we get from connecting with others
that give us hope and courage.
I mean, even that lactic acid, that metabolic byproduct
of exercise, that lactic acid seems to have an antianxiety
and antidepressant effect.
This is a crazy stuff.
It's not just an endorphin rush,
it's like at every level of our biology.
When we move, our brain is like,
I guess we have to do this thing called life.
And so, for people like me who've struggled with anxiety
or depression, this idea that you can convince your brain
to wanna fully engage with life and in a brave way
or in a hopeful way through movement is so phenomenal.
How does competition play into this?
'Cause, if we talk about movement, a subset of movement
is sports, sports being inherently competitive.
There has to be healthy aspects to this,
but also unhealthy aspects to this.
Yeah, I mean, so competition is a major human drive
and there's a lot of psychological benefits to it.
So when people tell me that they love competition,
like my sister is more like this than me.
It's like one of our fundamental differences.
She loves to compete, she loves to improve,
she loves mastery.
And I just sort of, I don't know,
that doesn't motivate me at all.
So I think the really healthy,
positive sides of competition, one is if you're competing
as a team or with a group and the tremendous bonds
and what you learn from cooperating in order to compete,
that seems like it has tremendous benefits.
And that even if you look at children who are teenagers
who are engaged in different types of sports,
it looks like there are more psychological benefits
to being involved in team sports
than individual competitive sports
because there can often be so much pressure
on the individual to be the best
without some of those other social forces
that come into play when you're working with others.
And I think the other thing that's so helpful
and healthy about competition is when it's really more
about mastery, that you have a sense of setting goals
and moving toward them.
And that they're personally meaningful.
And you sense yourself as somebody who can set goals
that are difficult and work toward them and meet them.
And that a whole chapter about overcoming obstacles
and the very definition of hope is to have a goal
that's meaningful, to believe you have the resources
to meet it and there are steps you can take.
And I think there are forms of competitive movement
that will really allow you to access
that whole experience of hope.
All right, well, I wanna bring the focus back on
to new year's resolutions.
And I think one thing that happens with a lot of people
is they're faced with this decision of like,
oh I have this goal, I wanna do this thing.
Do I just go whole-hog all in overnight
or do I take little bites out of this and do it slowly
in a way that doesn't completely upend my entire lifestyle.
Yeah, I'm mystified by people who believe
there's an answer to that question.
Of course, it depends.
You must get that question every day though.
Yes, and the thing is is you start where you are
and you do what you can do,
and you do it in the way that feels like the right way
to do it for you.
And whichever path you choose, you don't tell yourself
that's it or I failed.
There are some people who will take the baby steps.
They get that goal down to the tiny thing they can do
tomorrow and feel successful.
And then they find that they don't actually feel successful
because they don't see the benefit of it
or it doesn't have a deep meaning to them.
So you should give yourself permission.
Okay, you need to go harder on this.
What's the version of this
that when you finally get to do it
you're gonna feel like that's a triumph.
And then you give yourself as much time as you need to
to get to that point.
If you feel like you wanna go all in
and then you find out a month later
this is not working the way you had intended,
that it was a learning experience.
I think people shouldn't believe
that there are these tricks to behavior change
that are beyond what your intuition can lead you to.
If you are clear about what you care about
and you're willing to experiment
and not give up the first time it doesn't go as planned.
Right, I think that's super wise.
I think that these things are all about getting caught up
in some kind of future tripping or tripping over,
stories that we tell ourselves about the past.
And the truth is all we have is what we're doing right now.
And I kind of love the way 12 step does it.
It's just like, you don't have to,
like you don't have to worry
about whether you're gonna stay sober for 10 years.
Like, what are you doing right now?
Is your head gonna hit the pillow tonight
or you're gonna drink before you go to sleep tonight?
Like, that's all you got to worry about.
Like those tiny and perceptible things
that in the grand scheme of things seem small,
but actually are the levers that move everything.
Yeah, I think one example I often think about.
So one of the most difficult things to do
is to quit smoking.
There are some people who can do it cold Turkey
and I've talked to people who they made that decision
and they just did it.
And for whatever reason it worked for them,
it was an aha moment.
But there's research showing that if you can delay
the first cigarette of the day by five or 10 minutes,
that that increases your chance of quitting.
So like that seems totally possible.
Delay the first cigarette by five minutes
and that's something you could choose to do tomorrow.
And to know that both of those are pathways
to the same place.
And you don't always know at first
which one's gonna work for you,
and there's a million paths in the middle
that looked like something else.
Well, let's talk about what it is that you do.
Like, in your estimation,
what are the most important things that...
And again you can preface this
with whatever caveats you want.
But what do you think are the most important things
that people should be Doing or looking after
on a daily basis to kind of take out an insurance policy
against aging, given the current state of knowledge
and understanding.
That's well put.
Okay, now I feel free to speak 'cause I don't endorse
and I don't recommend.
I think the most important thing for anybody
to live healthier for longer.
If there was just one thing I could say,
it would be eat less often.
Don't eat three meals a day.
I literally think that that people who recommend three meals
plus snacks, trying to keep your glucose levels
always at a pretty high level
are doing the world a disservice.
And I'm gonna go out on a limb
to say that a lot of nutritionists would disagree with me.
But I've been doing this for 30 years,
I've seen what happens to people and animals
when you restrict their food.
And it it's all good.
I mean, you don't want malnutrition or starvation, of course
but putting the body in a state of want every day
for as long as you can do it.
I do it, like I said, hopefully till late afternoon dinner.
That's the easiest and best thing you can do.
Other things are the high intensity interval training
or jumping up and down with weights in a swimming pool,
almost drowning, that's pretty good.
You're going back tomorrow, right?
Well, I will do it again actually.
Now I actually think I know not to go too far
into the deep end.
But honestly we now know we all have the power
with the scientific basis to actually live
at least 15 years longer.
So there are actually, and I talked about this,
I think on Twitter recently that there are five things
that are pretty obvious and easy to do
that'll give you 15 years.
And that's just off the top of my head.
Things like, exercise, the fasting,
don't eat too much, eat the right foods,
try to be plant-based, get sleep, have social network.
That gives you 15 years, that's amazing.
That's not even going delving deep into my book,
which takes it to another level of what the best exercise
and supplements probably are.
So that's the good news.
I do list a lot of things.
We could talk for hours about what I do.
Page 304, you'll see more.
I'm conscious that we have a microbiome
that needs to be healthy.
So I'd make my own special yogurt,
which I mix my reserve trawl in.
I think I'll release the recipe of that pretty soon
to the in the newsletter, if anyone would like to make it.
So these are the things.
On the, sorry to interject,
but you sort of said, eating plant-based,
predominantly plant-based.
I mean, a lot of that is informed by the relationship
between excessive protein intake
and that impact on aging, correct.
Well, it's both--
From your perspective in the work that you're doing.
So the Plant-based food.
I think a little bit of meat is fine,
especially if you work out
and you're trying to bulk up some muscle.
But I think that what we've learned
is by studying the Sardinians and the Okinawans
is that those diets are the best for humans.
And they are mostly plant-based
with a little bit of meat like fish.
So why does that work?
Okay, why do we think that works?
The two reasons, one is that you don't want to overload
on some types of amino acids,
which you'll find in meat.
Leucine, isoleucine, valine.
These turn off our body's defenses
through a pathway called mTOR.
There'll probably be a Nobel prize awarded for that stuff
by the way, it's big deal, mTOR.
But if you're always eating a lot of protein
in terms of meat, then you'll never really optimize
your body's defenses.
So I try to eat plant based foods,
but there's another thing that most people miss,
which is the Xeno hermetic molecules from plants.
You get those, you don't get those from meat as much.
So what do you make of the carnivore diet?
Yeah, I'm on the other side.
It is an interesting phenomenon.
Just sort of culturally to go
how did this suddenly happen?
And there's a cohort of people who are all about just,
that's all they eat.
This hasn't been going on for very long.
This story very much has yet to be fully told.
But if somebody is listening to this
and perhaps was flirting with the idea of that,
I mean, what would be your response to that person?
Well, so I'm a scientist,
so let's talk some science briefly.
What you do when you activate this mTOR pathway
is you're telling your cells in your body,
the times a good, you've just caught a mammoth, basically.
And now's the time to build your body
and actually fix things, heal things and grow.
And it turns out that there are two things
your body can do.
There's grow and then there's on the other hand,
the other side of the balance is to protect.
Growth, protect, growth, protect.
And if you're always in this growth mode
by telling your body, now's the time.
You got your amino acids, grow.
That's great when you're young and middle-age,
you'll bulk up.
You'll feel good, you'll actually bone energy more.
You'll lose bit of fat.
But longterm, you're gonna sacrifice your longevity
in my view because you're not turning on
your body's defenses, which typically it turned on
when your body senses that there's adversities.
There's a need.
Yeah.
So being hungry and eating plants
are gonna be telling your body times are not as good,
we've run out of mammoth meat, let's hunker down.
But you could--
We're on our own, so we're gonna have to do
the heavy lifting here.
It's basically catalyzing these systems,
these biological systems to protect the body.
And in turn, promote longevity
versus, oh we've got an endless supply of food
coming in here, we can just shut everything down
because we don't have to worry about it.
Right, think of it this way.
When we're young, our defenses are on hyper alert.
Our bodies don't get diseases.
You don't find babies with Alzheimer's disease.
The cells know how to repair and defend against issues.
By eating a lot of meat, I think what you'd likely
to be doing is accelerating that process towards older age.
So 'cause your body will be in a growth state
but you won't be turning on your body's defenses.
And actually as you get older,
your defenses go down and down and down.
And that's one of the main reasons
that we end up getting old.
So you gotta get your defenses up like you're baby.
Speaking of which, I've been on much healthier diet
the last few years including intermittent and fasting,
including the supplements that I've got written on page 304.
People say, "Oh, I'm not noticing anything,"
after maybe two weeks on the supplement.
Of course, you're not gonna see that.
I've been doing it for, some of them for 10 years.
But what I've noticed most recently
with my current lifestyle, all of these things combined
the biggest things that has changed for me
is that I don't get sick anymore.
That's amazing.
I used to be the kind of guy that would go
from one cold to another.
I haven't had a sniffle in years.
I can't remember the last time I had a cold
and I'm on planes, people are sneezing on me.
I'm shaking hands with people pretty much all the time.
So my immune system must be on hyper alert.
And why is that good.
If you ask a centenarian, "What about your younger years
"in your '50s, '60s,"
They'll say, "I never got sick, never got a cold.
"My father's like that, he doesn't get colds either."
Yeah, I mean the kind of underlying theme in the book
and in your work is this idea
that there is no biological law that we need to age.
Like we just sort of accept that as a truism.
But in fact, that doesn't necessarily hold water.
No, no, nobody has any reason to say
that we have this clock that cannot be changed.
In fact, what we've learned going back to the Hogarth clock
is that about 80% of our lifestyle,
80% of our health in old age is due to our lifestyle
and how we live and only 20% is genetic.
And actually that that's done by studying twins,
who some smoke, some don't, some do all the stuff.
Your genes are not your destiny.
That's the good news.
So what that means is it's up to you.
And if you wanna be frail or to be honest, dead at 80,
go for it, we know how to do that.
Do everything that the marketing people want you to do.
Eat the cake, sit on your fat ass and watch movies.
That'll get you there pretty quickly.
But fortunately, in part, thanks to new media like this,
we can actually all talk about what we think are the ways
to extend lifespan and not be frail in old age.
Like my father, I talk about him a lot.
I'm very proud of him as a beacon of hope.
At 80, he's still running around like he's 25.
He's got no aches or pains, very sharp minded
using all sorts of high tech,
lifting more weights than I can, actually.
And our trainer who's currently training
the two of us together.
He says, "You know what?"
I think my dad was dead lifting, what was it?
Something like 180 pounds, something a lot.
And he said, "The last 80 year old that I trained
"was learning how to get out of a chair."
Yeah, you post something on Instagram.
He's in the squat machine or whatever just killing it at 80.
The guy's in his second career,
he's had this kind of resurgence and vitality
as a result of finding new purpose and meaning.
And he's also somebody who's been on your kind of protocol
for a while at this point.
And to see him in the gym at 80 crushing it,
it's very inspiring.
Well, I think most of us can achieve that in life.
Now there will be unlucky people, of course,
diseases still hit us, but most of us are wasting our lives
because we're basically,
not you, but most people don't think about their longevity.
They think, oh, when I'm old, I'll deal with that
when it comes.
But now in early in midlife is the time to invest
because it'll pay off dividends later in life.
There's something about running
and that solitude, that accompanies,
that gives you the space and the capacity
to kind of wrestle with those things
and get clarity for yourself.
I mean, there's a monologue in the film,
I think it's after you've left Aspen
and you're in the snow and in the Rockies where you say,
look running was about competition for most of my life,
measuring myself against others and a clock,
but it's become a process
of not just connecting with other humans,
but a process of self discovery.
And that's a huge theme in everything that you do
and in this beautiful movie.
Yeah, and I think if most of us that do run
or walk or bike or pursue something with consistency
year after year, I think if we really look
at what it's doing for us, I think that a lot of us
will find the same things.
And this is something that I tell people
and running has been my thing,
but I don't think that's necessarily
the thing for everybody.
I think that knitting could be that thing,
crochet, badminton.
I just think for me, I chose this activity
over 20 years ago, 25 years ago
and I've stuck with it for 25 years.
And when you stick with something for that long,
whether it's an activity or a person,
you're gonna continue to learn so much more about that.
But also in more importantly,
you're gonna learn so much more about yourself
and this thing just keeps changing
and changing and changing.
And it's that consistency that allows
for that to happen.
So lots of people have run across America.
Yeah.
I had just had this guy, Ravi Balanger on the show
who did it last year.
He did it in 75 days.
My friend Mike Posner just walked across America.
But most people that do this,
do it with an RV and a lot of support.
And that support tends to be off camera.
You know what I mean?
Conveniently, yeah.
But you decide to do this unsupported.
And for a vast majority of the entire expedition,
it's just you with a very light backpack
and a tarp and a ground cloth and a little bit of food.
And basically that's it.
Yeah, so, I mean, I've been at this sport
for quite a while.
I wouldn't say that I have a huge following
but I do have people that are paying attention
to what I'm doing.
And for me personally, it doesn't seem right
to put this project out there
in a way that I don't think is accessible
to a normal person.
And by that, I mean I don't think most people
can pull together an RV in the funds to pay for a person
and gas and food for multiple people for months on end.
Conversely, I do think that people,
a lot of people, ideally, if you're younger
and you have the physical capability,
can put together the funds and the time
to do it in the same way that I did.
And maybe you're not doing it--
It's funny, 'cause there's a little bit
of an irony in there because you're like,
I'm gonna do this super extreme thing
to show how doable it is for everybody.
And maybe not everybody, but I do believe
they've got several thousand people
starting the Appalachian trail these days.
And I think the Appalachian trail is awesome.
Like there's no doubt about it,
but how much are you really gonna learn about,
you're gonna learn a lot about yourself
and you're gonna learn a lot about trail culture.
But how much are you really gonna learn
about the United States in this greater context?
It's a form of escapism
and that's sometimes exactly what we need,
is to escape what's going on outside of our front door.
But for me personally, I needed to explore something
a lot deeper than just myself
and just the physical capabilities of something like that.
So, I set a budget for myself.
I did $1,000 a month
$5,000 total for the five months I slept outside.
Most nights, I'd get a hotel or a motel
once a week or once every 10 days.
That increased more towards once every couple of days
towards the end as I started kind of losing it a little bit.
And I simply needed to go into a room
and lock the door and turn the AC on
and turn some mindless television on.
But for the most part at what I wanted to do
was to put it out there
that this is something that people can do
and that there's alternatives
to these to do in the Appalachian trail
or go into Europe for four months.
Like you can just pack a very light backpack
and see what's out there.
And it's really incredible when people see that all you have
is in your backpack and they ask you if you've got a gun
to protect yourself and like, no I don't have a gun.
To just putting yourself out there in a vulnerable position.
The amount of warmth and generosity that I experienced
was something that I never could have anticipated
in a million years.
People giving me every last dollar from their wallet.
There's the guy, what's his name?
James Steel, yeah.
Gives you 80 bucks or 160--
I said 180.
I said 80, it was 160.
It was $160 and...
He wasn't taking no for an answer.
No, it was amazing.
And that's when I kind of, I realized that people
in their own way want to participate in this thing.
A few years ago, so this is kind of something
that I think about.
And the best way for me to tell this
is to talk about someone else running across the country.
And that was Pete Kostelnik who did across the country
in 40, I'm gonna say 44 days,
it could have been a little quicker.
This is in 2016, so a year before
or a few months before I did mine.
He did this and he was doing 60 to 70 miles a day
for 45 days and broke the record that had stood for--
Unsupported.
That was very supported.
That was two or three RVs with several people.
Yeah, it was a big effort on for a lot of people
and he's sure to give them credit as well.
But for me personally, so I was in Wisconsin at the time
and I saw that he was going through Northern Illinois
and I got in my car and drove two and a half hours
just to run with him for few miles.
'Cause it's like, I just felt like it was seeing
this mythical creature when someone's doing
something like that.
And even now to this day, now that I've done
this big journey, I still think it's a mythical creature.
It's like seeing a mountain lion or something.
And so I think that for me, that's what it was
for kind of when I came to realize
that some people, when they wanted to give me money
or just stop and talk, it was like, it is something rare.
There's the one guy who it looks like he turned his car
around when he saw you and he got out
and he's like, my friend's gonna freak out.
I read about you.
Like when you cross the state line or something like that.
So there was some awareness as you were passing through
of what you were doing.
Totally, in certain areas.
I don't know why it was in certain areas.
It was Oklahoma and Arkansas
where I received the most amount of generosity and warmth.
And then when I got to California,
ironically, it was nothing.
It's interesting like that.
I think what I appreciate most
is there's a vein of humility and vulnerability
that infuses this effort and the other things
that you've done.
And this trans-Americana journey
is almost like this performance art piece
that is part de Tocqueville, part Henry David Thoreau.
Like I'm gonna light out on America
and learn about democracy and connect with people
to try to better understand them,
better understand myself and better understand
what is required to unite us and bring us together.
Totally.
And you took your time,
like the priority wasn't the running,
the priority was the connection.
Yeah.
And the funniest thing that I encountered
or the most interesting thing that I encountered
when I went across the country
is that I thought I would be talking politics all the time
and it never came up.
It was just like when you're doing something like that,
when people see something like that,
they don't wanna ask you what your political views are,
they wanna ask you about like what you're doing
and what you're seeing out there.
And it just becomes really incredible
that so much of this stuff just kind of dissolves away.
And you realize that...
And I think I say the same thing in the movie coming out
is that I think, I don't think so, I know so.
We're way more similar than we are different.
I think that we're 90% similar and 10% different.
And that 10% difference has become inflated
so that we think that it's 90%, but it's not.
Right, it's exploited.
And it's leveraged by the media to further divide us.
Totally.
And I subscribe to my own media
and a lot that's been brought to my attention
over the past couple of years with talk of fake news
and all of these things is coming to terms
with that the media that I pay attention to is also biased.
And it's not just Fox news, like NPR is also biased.
We've all got these biases.
And we like to think that we're right
about our convictions, but the reality
is that there's a million different paths out there.
And if you grew up in Kansas, on a farm in Kansas
and you had that lifestyle
and I just see their voting habits,
their convictions as every bit as valid as mine.
And that's probably the biggest thing that I gained
from my run across the countries
is coming to terms with that.
Yeah.
So let's talk about Beauty Counter.
I mean, walk me through the inspiration for this
and what gave you this idea?
You know, there wasn't one specific thing,
but it was actually last night my friend Lila Rose
is in town from New York visiting.
And it was Lila, Lila had watched an Inconvenient Truth
and became super passionate
about the environmental health movement and said to me,
"You need to watch this film.
"You're loud, you're direct, you are connected.
"And I think you should pay attention
"to what's going on with the environment."
And so I watched "An Inconvenient Truth"
and for whatever reason that movie rocked my world.
It was just the first time,
I know it's almost embarrassing to admit this,
but it was the first time that I truly paid attention
to the fact that things that I was doing,
that were doing in my daily life, that my very existence
was wreaking havoc on the earth.
And so I became focused on the environmental health movement
and started to really make changes in my life.
Over the next year or two,
I also had a situation where I had a woman
who was taking care of our kids or Phoebe at the time,
my oldest, who was our nanny.
I was working, full-time running best in company.
And at 31, she was diagnosed with a non HPV related
cervical cancer and within 11 months she had died.
And so I was watching this young, beautiful
amazing woman die in front of me.
I was watching all these friends of mine
struggle with fertility issues or giving birth
to kids who had pretty significant health issues.
I looked at what was happening in the environment.
I thought like something's gone terribly right
and maybe I need to do something about it.
And it wasn't about beauty or Beauty Counter at the time.
It was just, how do I start to become,
how do I educate myself on what's actually going on?
That's there so that can be a vocal point for change.
And there's kind of this epiphany moment
when you're using products on your kids,
thinking 'cause they have the words natural on them
or you think you're using the right brand or whatever.
And then looking at the ingredients label
and doing a little research and realizing
that the gap between what you're being told or sold
and the truth is pretty vast.
I thought I was that has that whole foods shopper.
I was the mom that was going to local farm stands
as eating organic.
I mean, I thought I was doing all the right things.
I gotten rid of all our plastic.
I was washing my floors with water and vinegar.
And then I was looking at this and my kids,
I had two kids in the tub and it was a natural foaming
oatmeal bodywash from a leading drugstore brand.
And I thought, I mean, it looks like oatmeal,
it smelled like oatmeal kind of to me.
And then someone told me
about the environmental working group, skin deep database.
And I took a look at it and I was like,
holy shit, it was like eight out of nine for toxicity.
And I was pretty outraged.
So that really was another trigger point for me.
That's when I started switching all of my family's products.
But the one thing that I couldn't find for myself was just
I couldn't find any skincare cosmetics that I wanted to use.
And there just wasn't anything out there.
And the more that I learned, the more that I realized
that we had laws that were incredibly outdated,
the more I realized that there were harmful chemicals
in our products, I wanted to do something about it,
which is really why I started the company.
I consider myself to be somebody
who's fairly up to speed on environmental issues.
And certainly I'm the first to say
that governmental regulatory bodies
are not necessarily looking out for your best interests,
but even I was shocked when we were talking.
You were telling me last year
about the extent to which the FDA is just this paper tiger
when it comes to protecting people on the cosmetic
and kind of skincare front.
Yeah, I mean, I think that...
Someone was asking me the other day, why people worry,
why they feel safe.
Why do people feel safe in the United States
in terms of the products on the shelves.
And I was saying that in the food industry,
there are two things I think that are different
about skincare and cosmetics.
And just for clarity purposes,
I know you have a lot of men that listen to you
talk about things.
This, isn't red lipstick, this is deodorant, sunscreen,
body lotion, anything that we're putting on our bodies,
any of those things.
I think that two things are different.
When you eat something that's really bad for your body,
you typically get sick.
Like right away.
You feel it whereas--
There's an immediate direct reaction.
Whereas if you're putting on sunscreen or body lotion,
you could go your whole life and you would never
necessarily know that it was harmful to your health.
And then the second thing is,
I mean, yes if you have an allergic reaction,
but in the absence of allergic reactions,
people would just continue to put stuff on their body.
They wouldn't know about it.
And I think the second thing that's different
is that the FDA in the food industry has the ability
to recall product when it's known to be harmful to health.
If there's a seminal outbreak or whatever it is,
they can immediately pull it from the shelf.
But what people don't realize in the United States
is that when it comes to skincare and cosmetics,
they do not have the ability to recall product.
They can suggest, but they cannot take action.
That is shocking to me.
So play that out.
Like there's a cosmetic product or some skin lotion
that's on the shelves at every store.
And it's got proven toxic chemicals
that have been established to link directly
to some kind of poor health condition.
And the FDA is absolutely powerless to compel the industry
to remove it.
Correct.
And so there are a couple of things
that are not happening with the FDA.
First and foremost, we are not screening chemicals
for safety before we put them
into the products that we use.
Also shocking.
Yeah, so less than 10% of the 85,000 chemicals
that have been introduced into commerce
have been tested for safety.
And about 10,000 of those are commonly used
in personal care products.
So let's just say a solid 9,000 plus have never been tested
for safety on human or environmental health.
Then you combine that with the lack of regulation
where people can claim natural pure botanical,
whatever they want in skincare and cosmetics,
and there's no regulation.
So for example, a year or two ago,
there was an article about aloe based products.
They tested 38 aloe based products
across department stores and drug stores.
And they found that not a single one of them
had one little drop of aloe in them.
And then the third type of scenario is this scenario.
And an example would be Brazilian blowout
or there's one called wen haircare,
where they've had over 20,000 complaints of hair loss,
permanent hair loss for children and women.
And yet they can't--
Is that a shampoo or something?
Yeah, and it's still on the shelves.
And same with Brazilian blowout where the people
who are administering that hair straightening treatment
were getting incredibly sick,
but they can't do anything about it.
'Cause it had over 40% formaldehyde
and think about you're heating up formaldehyde
and blowing it all over and everyone's breathing it in.
The FDA can't do anything about it.
And that's why at Beauty Counter,
we're so focused on our advocacy efforts
because we need to update these outdated laws.
How did we get to this point?
I mean, look, I think there are a number of things.
I think first of all, there was a brief moment in time
in 1938 when the Federal Food Drug and Cosmetic Act
passed where Americans were protected.
But that was prior to these 85,000 chemicals
coming into commerce post World War II.
And so a lot of the leading companies
that are manufacturing products,
a lot of large conglomerates
started making these products
when they probably thought they were totally safe.
Why wouldn't they have thought they were safe?
And now I think that the challenge becomes
how do you undo this?
And how do you, when you're sitting
with relentless capital markets
and you take your share price down or whatever you do,
do the right thing and you take a massive hit.
I think people are scared to change.
And I think that we haven't updated major federal laws
since 1938, I mean, it's been over 80 years.
So--
The governing law in this
that kind of covers this entire landscape
is one law that was passed in 1938.
One and a half pages of legislation
that govern an $80 billion industry
that still allow for chemicals of concern
that are known to be cause,
that cause cancer, linked to endocrine-disrupting,
all those things, neurotoxicity.
Those chemicals are in our products
and the government has not taken action
on the federal level.
So a big part of your mission
and why you founded this company is this advocacy piece
of getting these laws changed.
And part of that has been, you go into Washington DC
and banging on doors to get people to pay attention to this.
There's a new bill that you're trying to advocate for vote.
But this has been going on for years,
like since 2015 or something like that.
So when we launched, from the very beginning I said,
there are three things that we need to do
that are really important.
We need to educate because we knew that less than 20%
of Americans had any idea
that there are chemicals of concern.
And I didn't look, I've always said,
as we needed no one needed another beauty brand.
And I mean, I'm not even a beauty.
I wasn't even a beauty person.
Like I never even...
It wasn't my thing, but what we needed to create a movement
for better cleaner safer products for everyone.
And so education's always been a core component
of our business.
And using commerce as an engine for change
has also been a core component
'cause I do think that consumer brands
can move markets faster than legislative reform
that will ever happen.
On the advocacy side, we started from right out of the gate
when I was raising capital, I said to all of our investors
we're gonna take this all the way to Washington.
You need to be comfortable with that.
And we started immediately, the minute we had any skill.
In 2013 we started to go out there and talk about it.
And we started on the state and federal level.
And now we do this in Canada as well.
I didn't say this earlier, but not only have we not updated
the laws since 1938, the EU banned
or restricted depending on the chemical
about 1400 ingredients well over a decade ago.
When I started Beauty Counter, we had 11 to their 1400
and now we're up to a whopping 30.
So we had to get out there and pound the pavement
in Washington.
We needed to let them know that it's time to change.
The reality is we are just the tip of biology
on the earth.
The microbiome was always for life.
It's never against life.
If it appears that the microbiome is threatening us
or killing us, it's because we have misaligned ourselves
with nature at a large level
and we need to realign ourselves with that.
And we need to start to think about what it looks like
to be within our moment, living as light beings
at a high vibration in space and time
with high consciousness.
With a respect for human life,
with a respect for animal life,
that's not happening on the planet.
People are right now saying again,
oh China makes this happen every year
because they have all these animal markets
and food markets and everything else.
And the reality is, yes, that actually is a problem.
When we're killing 60 billion animals a year
for human consumption, that's a global problem.
And that's not a Chinese problem,
that is a global problem that we're killing
60 billion animals.
But a bigger problem that those 60 billion animals
are largely being held in captivity
in these extreme toxic inhumane levels of management.
And so if we see viruses coming out of that,
well that's the microbiomes check on the reality
that we live in.
There are checks and balances and biology,
certainly that work better than the checks
and balances in our government.
And life is gonna have to be redirected
if we oppose health and ecology on that level.
Really what you're getting at is developing
a healthy dose of humility.
And the recursive theme and everything
that you've been talking about
comes back to having in there being equanimity
in terms of our relationship to the planet,
whether it's our food systems,
whether it's how we interact with each other,
we are out of whack and it's, nature's way of reminding us
that we need to reset and pay attention.
And again, I keep saying this,
but I don't wanna minimize what's happening.
There are a lot of people who are scared
and there are many people who are suffering
and people are dying.
But I think if we can really connect with this humility,
we have an opportunity to embrace the opportunity
to return with a more sort of synergistic relationship
with our planet.
I mean, Farmer's Footprint is a perfect example of that.
By returning to what is natural and cyclical
with the planet, these farmers have been able
to find new life and with that a new happiness
and a new lifeline for their families.
And the domino effect of that is profound.
And if we can extrapolate on that example
to reflect back upon our own relationship to the planet
and our behaviors and our consumer choices,
I think I can be highly instructive going forward.
At the same time, many of these things
that we're talking about involve systems
that are out of the control of the average consumer.
How much impact can I really have on our global supply chain
on our food system, on policy, on economics,
on what Big Pharma decides to do, et cetera.
But what we can do is seize this moment of solitude
and Seaquest duration to really inventory and reflect
on our own behavior patterns
because the ecosystem that resides within each of us
is just a microcosm of the macrocosm
that we're experiencing externally right now.
And for me, I've been kind of thinking about this
through that lens, like how am I living?
What in my life is not in balance, where can I live more
in alignment with nature's cyclical rhythms?
Where can I find more balance in my day to day routine.
And where am I blind or in denial about things
that I'm that are perpetrating a problem
that recurs in my own life.
And I think the more that we can all adopt that practice,
I think we all kind of emerge out of this
assuming that we can emerge out of it healthy,
more empowered and stronger and more capable and humble.
And in a better position to create that world
that we all can imagine for ourselves.
And yet seems so out of grasp at the moment.
Absolutely, that's beautiful.
So, wanna just close with reaching out to the physicians
and nurses and nurse practitioners and PAs
that are out there right now on the front lines in New York
and Philadelphia and all the other cities
that are starting to see the impact of this,
the situation we're in right now.
And I just wanna acknowledge your effort
and the fear that you're feeling
and the exhaustion you're feeling
and a state of overwhelm that you sense
and the vulnerabilities that you're so poignantly
aware of right at the moment.
And I just want you to know that we so deeply appreciate
your commitment and your efforts in this time.
We know the extremity of the situation you're in
and look forward to the end of that and the coming weeks
as this passes over us.
And in the meantime, I just wanna reflect for a moment
about, again, redefining your role
just like we did with the garden.
We need to let go of maybe the expectations
that you're gonna heal everybody
and you're gonna save everybody's life.
And we need to really look at both sides of the physician
or care team's experience.
On the one side, we are all trained to be technicians,
how we're trained to adjust the knobs on the ventilators,
were trained to adjust the drips on the IVs.
We're trained to read all the data
and we're trained to write all the notes
and look at all the risk factors
and fill out the insurance forms.
All of that is coming to a crisis point.
It's not working.
And that happens every day in an ICU
where all the technology at hand finally fails
and there's nothing more we can offer.
And the patients die.
And then there's a second half to the journey
that is the definition of that being a physician state,
or being a caretaker, being a nurse is when you set down
the machinery and you sit down with the patient and say,
we've done our best, we have done everything
we know how to do.
And we acknowledge that you are alive
and we acknowledge that you are here with us in this moment.
And we acknowledge that you're gonna likely expand
to the other side of this rebirth that we call death.
And in that time with your patients right now,
I want you to know that we see the greatest victory
right there, 'cause ultimately as physicians
and practitioners, we don't actually save lives.
We don't have that level of capacity or responsibility.
Life is something much greater than human.
Life is a gift and it's not your responsibility
to maintain it.
It's your responsibility to show up
and bring the highest level of compassion skill
capacity that you can, but you will do your highest work
when you recognize that this miraculous life that we live,
this miraculous gift of life is transient.
It is temporal, and it is our calling to be present
with that and acknowledge it
and see the beauty in every phase of it.
And when you've got a young person who's dying
or an elderly person who's dying,
it's easy to get caught up in the emotions of the loss,
but we need to get better and celebrate the moment
of acknowledging the gain.
This is a life well lived.
This is a person who has created in their lifetime,
this is the person who's loved in their lifetime,
this is a person who's really in it
for the big big story of what it means to be human.
And this was a soul that came in on purpose
and has lived some version of that purpose.
And we acknowledge that.
And so I hope that in the same way
that the messy garden can start to look like a victory,
the mess of healthcare can be very victorious
if we recognize each other's humanity.
And if we really embrace the beauty of human life
and consciousness, that becomes often most poignant
and most obvious when we're about to lose it.
And we let go of that human consciousness
to plug into something much, much bigger.
And I hope that you get to see
as the veil thins with your patients right now,
you get to get to see that other side
and realize that they have no fear
on the other side of that veil.
And so their coming back and forth out of cautiousness
and back into consciousness in those last few minutes
and hours and days, I hope that you get a glimpse
of the beauty on the other side,
and a state of being that's free of fear,
free of sense of loss and only sees the opportunity
and expansion and light.
And so take this opportunity to let down the expectations
on yourself and give up on a sense of failure.
Let go of your sense of failure
in those moments when the ventilators failing,
actions failing, the numbers are going south.
Don't let that define your success.
Be present with your patients right now.
Let, let them not die in vain,
let them be part of the message
that this virus is trying to teach us.
Let their journey be part of you.
Reach out to them and hold their hands right now
and give them a sense of deep purpose
in this extreme thing that they've been called to.
If they're called to pass right now,
let them know it's not in vain,
that we're gonna learn from this,
that we are realizing that we have taken too many steps
away from our purpose, our real nature,
our real potential and that they are doing
their highest work right now in walking the journey
of dying in this situation to teach us a deep lesson
of what it means to be connected
and disconnected and a pathway towards reconnection.
And let them know that their highest victory is at hand
and that they are part of the rise of human consciousness
and not the collapse of biology on planet.
That's what I want you to grab right now
and just know that I had just deep gratitude
for your courage to keep showing up.
Love you, brother.
Thank you.
First of all, congratulations on the success
of the "Blue Zones" kitchen cookbook.
I mean, once again, there you are at the top
of the bestseller list.
It's pretty cool to see.
Well, I spent years writing deeply research books
that were, I like to think artfully crafted
when it came to the pros and only to discover
what America really wants is beautiful pictures
and bean recipes.
That's it, right.
But this is not an ordinary cookbook.
I mean, this unfolds much like one of your expeditions.
This is a deep dive into these cultures as much as it is
about here's the thing you can make in your kitchen.
Well, yeah, I, I cringed at the title cookbook
because actually we tried to make it more like a 250 page
national geographic article.
So I wrote...
The introductions are all science driven,
the science of why these foods are helping these people
make it to 100.
I think we have the best national geographic photographer
in this genre, David McClain shot all the photos.
There's no studio shots there,
it's all editorial photography.
And the recipes, none of them are recopied down.
I sat on a stool and watch these old ladies cook
and captured the recipes and then sent them here
to Los Angeles actually where they were corrected
in test kitchens.
They don't have tablespoons and measuring cups
up in the "Blue Zone".
You sent the actual people or just...
No, just my observation.
But the thing is, this is a 500 year old food tradition
that is disappearing because in all these Blue zones,
the American food culture is coming
and replacing this way of eating
that has produced this statistically longest lived people.
20 year olds, aren't eating like this.
So I was sitting with 70, 80, 90, even 100 year olds
watching them cook the foods of their youth.
So this is almost say a project of anthropology
as much as a food book.
Creating an historical document.
I like to think it is.
And when you look at these Blue zones pillars movements.
Plant-based, plant slant diet, faith, friendship,
connectivity, all of these things,
are they relatively evenly balanced?
They're interdependent with each other,
but is there one that stands out.
Did you write this Blue zones kitchen book
because the diet component of it is so important
or how do you think about how the interplay of all of those?
Yes.
To your point, it is a mutually supporting web of factors.
So people eat wisely, they move naturally every 20 minutes
because their life is underpinned with purpose.
They have a social network that makes this easy.
Their friends are doing these things
and they live in environments where the healthy choice
is the easy choice.
So they are definitely connected.
But the most important variable there is eating.
Americans probably lose six years of life expectancy
eating the standard American diet.
This is that middle age, by the way.
Overeating say a Blue zones diet which is largely beans,
whole grains, greens, nuts and tubers
and fruits and vegetables as well.
So the problem is except for a few people like you
with heroic discipline and a great community supporting you,
it's very hard for Americans to go plant-based
and whole food plant-based by the way,
it's not Twinkies and chips.
You need this whole foods plant-based diet
is the most important factor.
But the only way to do that
for the decades necessary to avoid a chronic disease
is have the right social network, live in the right place.
Having that sense of purpose
where it's important enough for you to be around
that you're gonna make the sacrifices every occasionally
to not order the hamburger.
Also in this is stuff about portion size,
time of day, when to eat.
Like one of the things you noticed
is like, well, the size of the plates that these people
are using is this different than in America.
And how does that dictate long-term how we...
So I'll spin out a couple of the insights
that I captured for Blue zones kitchen on how they eat.
First of all, they're cooking, no matter where you go,
they're only using about 20 recipes
or 20 ingredients rather over and over and over.
Because they know how to combine these ingredients
to create a symphonic deliciousness,
but not of different crazy foods or super foods.
No super foods, except for beans.
Beans is probably the super food.
Number two, they tend to consume all their food
in about an eight hour window.
Breakfast like a king, lunch like a prince,
dinner like a pauper.
Number three, they tend to say something before the meal
that marks a punctuation between their busy life
and now we're slowing down to eat,
like a prayer Adventists or the Sardinians
or Hara Hachi Bu, which is an Confucian adage
that the Okinawans say before every meal
to remind themselves to stop eating
when their stomachs are 80% full.
They tend to eat with their family.
They tend to not have electronics in their kitchen.
So they're not eating to their favorite song
or eating to their favorite TV show.
They tend to cook at home as opposed to going out.
These are all things that I would argue,
add to the ecosystem of eating
that produces long lived people
and the core of which being this,
knowing how to make plant-based food taste delicious.
Amazing work.
How's Kathy, is she good?
Kathy Freston, my cruciferous girlfriend who says hi.
She's the vegan vixen.
She's been a great influence on really an early pioneer
in making plant-based eating cool.
For sure, huge, huge influence on mainstreaming.
What we now kind of almost take for granted,
like, oh vegan options, pretty much everywhere you go.
But Kathy played a huge role.
Yeah, she got to Oprah to go vegan for awhile.
I know.
And Ellen Degeneress and Crossword Kitchens
which I argue is one of the best restaurants in Los Angeles
is all plant-based.
And that would have been seen as a heresy
15 years ago.
What, kind of also a big influence on you personally.
Like I think even in the time that I've known you,
you've had an evolution in terms
of your plant-based diet relationship.
Yeah, I've come to a plant-based diet
by observing that the diets
of the world's longest lived people.
And 95% of what they put in their mouth
is whole plant based food, but she comes at it
sort of the animal cruelty.
And I never even thought of that,
the occasional piece of meat I ate occasioned,
just horrible pain and suffering
from another sentient being.
My favorite statistics, she told me that an adult pig
has the intelligence of a three-year-old human,
spends his entire life in a cage he can't turn around in,
lives in its own feces, connects with its it's young
the same way we connect with our young,
wants to socialize, feels pain in the same way.
Yet lives a miserable life
and has a horrible death at the end
all in the service of bacon or pork chop.
And when you add that to the fact
that eating a plant-based diet is probably worth
six to eight years over eating a standard American diet,
it's just so overwhelmingly right
that you can't avoid it.
Not to mention the environmental considerations.
That's the third problem, yes.
What is the right question to ask right now?
Like if you're speaking to a white person,
like what are the things that they should be thinking about
and how can they contribute and participate in this
in the most effective way?
I think a great question is should be asking
how did we get here?
Because I listen to a lot of people
speak as if they have the answers,
again because of this event and recent events.
And the anger that you see
is not just because of these events.
This is anger that stretches back 400 years.
Because as an African-American, in our community
when we see something happen,
it's never just about the thing that happened.
It's typically about the history,
this is another thing that's happening.
So it like this is a natural thing.
We don't just look at Arberry's situation,
we don't just look at George Floyd or Breonna Taylor.
We literally, it's like a file that you just recall
the faces and names like that.
Or I could go back to Emmett Till immediately.
And your own personal experiences.
Yeah, personal experiences.
So I think a good question to ask is how did we get here?
And I don't think enough people ask that question.
I think for one reason, it's gonna force people,
particularly white folks,
to look at this country differently.
It's gonna force them to talk about white fragility.
What DeAngelis told talking about.
It forces them to look at themselves
because to be American, subconsciously is to be white.
And everything else is measured against that.
I've had people in conversations where the guy would say,
"I was in this room and it was a bunch of people's, diverse.
"Americans were there."
And then he began to list the African-American
or the black folks, Hispanics.
They weren't American, I guess.
But when he was saying American,
he was talking about the white folks that were there.
And he wasn't a bad person.
It was a great guy, but subconsciously,
he just associated American with white.
And that's typically what happens.
And so to look at how we got here
is to now have to open up yourself
to seeing this country differently.
'Cause I always asked the question,
when you say America is so great,
what's your definition of greatness and when.
Because if you're talking about power and military might
and prosperity, certainly.
If you're talking morally and being a just society,
you have to go back and help me understand when was that.
Because there's always been systemic
and legalized oppression in this country.
There's never been a decade, had never been a time
in history and our history that it wasn't the case.
And so I challenged that notion of greatness.
Do we have the potential to be, absolutely.
And so I think how do we get here
is a great question to ask.
And in addition to that, also I think people have to,
this is a time of courage,
a time of intestinal fortitude,
where white people also have to confront their ignorance.
When we don't know and that's exposed, that's vulnerable.
And it doesn't, I mean, this goes beyond race,
this is just human nature, human condition.
If we don't know something
and our current idea or point of view
or answer that we thought was true is shown not to be
by just based on evidence,
that's a very vulnerable position to be in.
No one likes their ignorance exposed.
But if you look at that, even that term ignorance
from just the sheer educational definition,
ignorance is the beginning of enlightenment.
It's learning.
You can't learn until you confront
and rustle through your ignorance.
That's the foundation or the fundamentals of learning.
So adults have to embrace the fear and the risk
of being vulnerable.
What they may say out of just sheer ignorance
is proven to be untrue.
Well, it requires a certain humility too.
And I'm uplifted because I'm seeing a willingness
to embrace this conversation
in a way that I can't recall in my lifetime
and that gives me hope.
But it's juxtaposed against a climate and a culture
that is more deeply entrenched in being right.
And there are silos and the division that we're seeing
right now, it's sort of a war between those two things
right now.
Social media fomenting this division across America
where people just wanna yell at each other
and no one is taking a pause to actually listen
and take stock and perform a little bit
of forensic self analysis.
But I think these events have led us to a point
where we are seeing a certain portion of the population
doing that.
I'm attempting to do that here today.
And I think that's really the only path to healing
and to really reconstructing society
around more equitable lines.
Rich, I think you're totally right.
You hit the nail on the head.
You have to be willing to have those kinds of conversations.
When intelligent people are stuck in their silos
and their echo chambers and spend more energy
trying to defend their position
than admit that this is a multifaceted complex problem
that is going to take rigorous and consistent attention to
in order to really right,
in order to really solve the problem.
Until we're willing to really embrace that,
then it's gonna be an uphill battle,
it's gonna be hard.
Because we feel more comfortable when we think we're right
or when we have the upper hand.
And so when you have people on all sides digging in
and having good points on every side,
but spending most of our energy trying to point out
where and why the other side is wrong
as opposed to instead of being on opposite sides
of the table, coming together on one side
and actually pouring all of that energy into the problem,
I think that's the heavy lifting that has...
And conversations like this is a start.
But I think what a message we wanna continue
to really advocate is after the protesting,
after the news cycle has died down,
after the shift in attention moves to something else,
will we have enough boots on the ground
committed to wrestling within the trenches
to right the wrong that we clearly see right now.
Yeah, that energy has to get channeled
into some kind of productive change
that is architected around strategies and tactics
to actually enact the changes that are necessary
rather than just sort of outrage that just dissipates
into the atmosphere.
Which is again, why you hear people
really pointing the spotlight on the dysfunction
within the justice system.
And you get a lot of people on one side
saying those are just bad apple cops
and deflecting the attention on no, this is just,
if we look at it in terms of a virus,
this is just a flare up of something
that is still alive on the inside.
And what we're seeing is just a flare up happening.
But if we just deal with the surface issue
and not deal with the root cause on the inside,
it's just gonna be a matter of time
before this little thing heals, but in months,
weeks, years, another flare up happens.
So we definitely to take this opportunity
to now do some some deep dive surgery
into the systemic issues that allow this thing to exist.
Switching gears a little bit,
another narrative that's out there
is that this problem is not for black people to solve,
it's for white people to solve.
So what is the role of white America
in redressing this, other than that you talked about the Els
and we need to educate people, we need to appreciate
the complexity of this.
We need time to heal, we need a longer conversation
that isn't bifurcated around political lines.
Like, how do the white people listening to this
wrap their heads around how they can be
a most productive member of this movement?
I go back and forth because I believe
that is voices of color that need to lead
because we feel it,
this idea, you can't lead me someplace you've never been
or you can't give to me what you've never had.
100%.
It's preposterous to think otherwise.
So there's a learning from voices of color.
But I think taking the power and the privilege
and being a part of helping to reach
the broader white community,
I think right now, that's whether it's in government,
those congressmen and women using their positions
to reach them, family members on the family level
reaching them, in corporations, reaching them.
I think, because we can't reach them, our job we can share
we can put pressure on, we can protest.
We can do all these things.
We can write books,
but they're not gonna listen to us necessarily.
So I think one way, this is just one,
it's not the only one.
This is one thing is, I ask white friends,
"You have to be the voice to reach the people
"that we're not gonna be able to reach
"on all these levels, wherever your influence is."
That's one way because I don't know what else we can do.
I really don't.
If you look at literature, you look at music,
you look at movies, you look at marches,
we've done it peacefully.
We've done it angrily, we've kneeled, we've knelt.
We've fist in the air.
We've used our bodies in ways.
That's one of the primary resources we have, our bodies.
We've done everything we know to do
and we're still here, not just incidents but a culture.
I think it takes the white allies
or whatever word you want to use for that
to be the voices advocating
in solidarity to the white community,
because they're not gonna listen to us necessarily.
Not all, some will, but the masses won't listen to us.
I think beyond the virus itself,
it's really pulled the veil on the fragility of our systems,
economic and political.
The fact that everything has ground to a halt
and our economy is basically frozen in time at the moment
and in essentially free fall.
And we're now seeing what happens when an economic system
that's premised on carrying large loads of debt
and businesses that are overly leveraged.
You know, this is potentially cataclysmic
and could send us into a depression,
at the very least a moment of repression
that we don't know how long it's going to last.
And it is opening up the conversation
about what a better economic system would look like.
Again, this is something
that you spent a lot of time thinking about.
You've written a book, "Sacred economics."
So how are you thinking about this moment
in the context of your economic thinking?
Yeah, it could go either way.
Just like on the medical level,
it could go either way, toward doubling down
on where we've already been going
and finally getting rid of all that alternative
and holistic stuff
or it could be like, wow, this wasn't working,
let's try something really different.
Why are we so vulnerable?
Why is our healthcare system so fragile?
We could go into this big reckoning and housecleaning
and reassessment of everything
all the way down to the bottom.
Same thing with economics, if nothing changes,
if we just continue on the path we've been on,
then this crisis is accelerating a long existing trend
of concentration of wealth and the destruction
of small business and the concentration of economic
and political power in fewer and fewer hands.
Because the crisis is decimating small
and medium sized businesses.
So the big ones can get bailed out,
they can get supported by the government.
It's a lot harder to do that for your local movie theater
or yoga studio or whatever.
People are getting along okay
without a lot of these small businesses.
Some of them will probably come back,
but we're looking at massive devastation
for small businesses and the self-employed,
even medium-sized businesses
and everything that depends the brick and mortar world,
like the local kinds of businesses.
So we could see a extension
of this longstanding trend of concentration of wealth.
People talk about, with the stimulus checks and stuff,
a universal basic incomes could be the start
of a universal basic income,
which could be a wonderful thing
or it could be a terrible thing.
It could be, well, sorry, you can't get a job anymore
unless you're a part of a shrinking elite,
but we'll give you your monthly pittance
as long as you do as you're told.
And don't misbehave and wear your ankle monitor
to make sure that your electronic hall pass
to make sure you're not at some unauthorized
on a central place, et cetera, et cetera.
And so most people are kind of on the door
except for a small elite.
And they can't get off it because the independent economy
that's not controlled by government
and huge corporations has been destroyed,
like we could see that.
Or we could see analogously to a holistic revival.
We could take stock and say,
wow we don't wanna keep going down this road,
what do we do to bring economic power back to the people
to redress the concentration of wealth.
And that could go along the lines of...
And this is a moment where we could take a different path.
We could institute some form of a debt Jubilee,
debt forgiveness, student loan, forgiveness
refinancing mortgages at zero interest.
There's many ways to bail out the debtors
rather than bailing out the creditors and the banks
and the large institutions.
And I hope that this is one of the things
I'd like to put onto the radar
is that we don't have to go back to normal.
Normal sucked.
Normal was like a road to hell.
Things were getting worse and worse
for more and more people.
And not just people, but for ecosystems.
For soil, for water, for the whales, for the elephants,
for the oceans.
We don't wanna go back to normal.
And now that normal has been interrupted,
maybe we can make a conscious choice
to go in a different direction.
That's the gift.
And that's what makes it an initiation.
Yeah, that's the gift.
It is the initiation.
I mean, you've talked about and written about yourself,
being somebody who is sort of always perceive
that just around the bend,
something like this would be coming
and it never seemed to come.
And now here it is, this moment in time
that is so unique and unprecedented
and yet rife with so much opportunity.
I mean, the argument certainly can be made
that this is the greatest opportunity
for consolidation of power and wealth
in our lifetime certainly.
And we're seeing that happening right now
and the large corporations are going to get their bailouts
and there's gonna be a decimation
of small businesses across the board.
And if that scale tips too far in that direction,
that becomes a scenario in which revolt and revolution
becomes a potential reality.
Short of that, we're also seeing on the other side
indicia of this gift economy.
We're having conversations about universal basic income
in a way we never have.
We're seeing people on social media
just getting out their Venmo and sending money to people
and over tipping and doing all of these kind of...
Engaging in these beautiful acts of humanity
that are casting a spotlight on the beautiful aspects
of what a different type of system could produce
that would bring us together and cultivate that community
and eradicate some of the separation that's...
Like you said, this is all an accelerant of these trends
and things that are already happening.
It's just being exacerbated right now.
And that's allowed us to have a heightened level
of attention.
And with that, my hope is that we can take stock of that
and really seize this moment where we're forced to stop,
when we're in repose to conceptualize
this better system for all.
Yeah, I do see both of those things happening
on the one hand, this outburst of humanity, solidarity.
That's what always happens when the confining routines
of normality waiver or dissolve.
Rebecca Solnit writes about this so beautifully in her book,
"A Paradise Built in Hell."
When there's an earthquake, when there's a flood,
when there's some natural disaster that sweeps away
the structures of society, it's not what one might expect
dog eat dog, looting and chaos
and the strong preying on the weak.
It's people getting together to take care of each other.
Whoever has some, a kerosene stove
they set up an outdoor kitchen
and whoever has food brings the food
and people, they start to take care of each other.
This natural altruism and community and solidarity emerges.
And you realize that it's been repressed
all the time by our systems and ideologies of separation,
but it's always laying there,
waiting for its moment to come back.
And this is such a moment.
As soon as normality waivers,
people can act on their long repressed impulse
to live the lives that we are in fact here to live,
which are not to maximize self-interest.
That is a substitute, a bribe to keep us
away from the lives that we're really here to live,
which are lives of service to life
and service to beauty
and service to something meaningful to us.
That's the only meaningful life and the only full life.
And to sell that off, to mortgage that
to mirror survival, safety, security, self protection,
that is a poor bargain that we make.
That leaves us feeling that we didn't even live life.
Instead we lived the life we were paid to live,
but what about my life
where I'm not afraid to die, at least,
yeah, maybe I have that fear
but there's something more important.
So that gets liberated in times like these.
And it's also showing us when you take something
that's happening unconsciously and put it starkly
in front of your face by showing us the extreme of it,
then the unconscious choice becomes conscious.
And that's what we're seeing.
It's like, okay, here's our destination,
here's where we were gonna be going.
A world of isolation, of distancing, of separation,
of polarization, of concentration of wealth
of no human contact, of no community.
Like we've been silently helplessly, unconsciously
moving toward that as if it were an inevitability
for a long time.
And now it's like the alcoholic waking up
and his spouse has left him and and he's in the hospital
or something like that.
And it's like, wow, this is taking me to a bad place.
And so it's a moment of reclaiming our sovereignty
and our collective ability to choose our future
rather than merely adapting to something that we see
as inevitable.
And what future will we choose,
it's being shown us by precisely this humanity
and solidarity that is breaking through the cracks
in the system.
That it's showing us the future we could go to,
a future where we're all in this together,
where we understand that your wellbeing
and my wellbeing are connected.
And even the wellbeing of other creatures
and that health and happiness and even real wealth
does not and cannot exist in isolation,
but only in community.
And so we can say, yeah, enough of this trajectory
of separation, now is the time to rejoin the community
of humanity and the rejoin the community of life.
That's the crossroads that we're at right now.
Taking pause and thinking how other people might feel
is not only one of the calls to action for this moment
that hopefully will go forward,
but I think that that's the work we need to do now.
So really think how do I make space for other people?
How do I make other people feel comfortable?
Again, to to say in running or something like that,
like how do we create a more just space in our communities.
I'm interested in kind of what unity and allyship
looks like to you.
Like, I'm just sitting here thinking I'm a white dude
I'm privileged, I come from a certain background.
We're in this moment and I really wanna be
as open as possible and as teachable as possible.
I wanna fully understand the breadth
and the depth of what we're contending with right here.
And I wanna be an ally.
And I'm very, I find myself feeling cautious
or somewhat paralytic around what to say and what to do
for fear of misstepping in a culture
in which a slight misstep on Instagram or in public
is met with, we were talking about before.
And not that I really care that much about any of that.
What I do care about is getting this right.
I'm interested in what that looks like
from somebody of your perspective.
That's an interesting thing.
And I think that's something that a lot of us
are thinking about.
And one of the things about double consciousness
is that I wasn't really thinking about that situation
you just described, like I don't think
a lot of black Americans that I've been in conversation with
over my life have been really talking
about paralytic white guilt.
Yeah, yeah.
So the wave of communications in the past several weeks
has been really fascinating.
Let me make it about me.
Yeah, I got, it was like.
Here's the thing, like is so funny
'cause all the white dudes are freaking out right now
trying to figure out what to say and what not to say.
And my black friends are like, relax man.
Like, we've been waiting for you, it's cool.
How do I get it right.
I was like, well I'm counting on you to get it right,
don't worry.
Like just chill out, join in.
Yeah, the whole paralytic idea of getting a right.
So I didn't even know,
like when after the George Floyd killing,
when, before we were really aware
and it was happening daily.
Like our experiences that our understanding
of the moment was setting in.
So when there was like so much white silence,
I was like, oh, okay, cool.
White people don't have anything to say, okay, cool.
And it was actually a real vacuum, a real deafening silence.
It was actually really incredible
because I was able to just think about the life
of a modern Ahmaud Arbery, Breonna Taylor, George Floyd
without so much noise.
And I was able to reach out and connect
to other black people in that space
and just have these emotional connections.
And what were those conversations like?
They were uncomfortable because you really have to,
I mean like everybody has a divestment
that they need to consider.
So you really have to let go of machismo
or these kind of like chauvinistic ideas
of our own vulnerability and fragility.
I keep coming back to this idea of love.
I know that's super obvious and basic
and people talked about it from time,
but Ahmaud Arbery's best friend say that it was weird
every time he would like leave from hanging out,
he would say like, I love you, man.
And he wouldn't leave until they said it.
And these are like young brothers sitting around
in rural Georgia at the carwash leaving work.
And like, that's a really insane and rigorous process
practice to do.
So when I called up all these brothers
and told them I loved them, it was rigorous from my end.
It was tough to reach out.
And man, for all the mistakes that I've made
and then I'm gonna continue to make
as soon as I walk out this door,
I just wanna keep thinking about love
and I wish that I would hope that this would be a moment
for people to reset and reflect on what that is.
And for all the little microaggressions
that we engage in or all the times
that we take around chitchat.
And anytime we just serve as a detractor to someone else
for no reason, all these things are adding up
to this giant feeling of psychic pain
that you can just feel.
Whether you're feeling it in America's cities
or you're feeling it in Ahmaud Arbery's killers,
like how abject were these guys
that they went into seek and destroy mode.
You know what I mean?
Like it's not too early to kind of think
about the spiritual poverty, the imaginative poverty
that racists feel.
You know what I mean?
So if we can kind of at least consider
what an ethic of love looks and feels like,
if we can just kind of like reset and refer back
to those basic civics that maybe
we thought we were gonna pursue as we got older,
that's really what I'm thinking about.
And I'm thinking about that, honestly in like a really corny
kind of social media way.
Like it's okay to be a white ally with 1047 followers.
And like here's the list and you're banging on
at white people.
But if then you're like going and getting into the DMs
and detracting from someone else,
if you're the purveyor of suspicion or innuendo
or kind of things, like you gotta think if our own
white supremacy is uninvestigated until very recently.
And that's black people, like black people
have a social sickness that we've inherited
from 400 years of experience in this country.
So everybody is on the docket right now
to investigate our own internalized white supremacy.
This is our chance to see beyond the speeches
that politicians are making.
This is our chance to think a little bit
beyond what our mainstream media is telling us.
And what does it mean for us?
And strangely, this opportunity has been a reset
on so many levels, but it's been a recent
on like my mindfulness practice.
And going back to the beginnings of that
and then just thinking about the ways
in which a mindfulness practice helps us
just think of things more clearly.
It's interesting.
You kind of think that meditation is like about
I come a guru on a mountain top or something like that,
but I've been reading and hearing some things lately
that it's like it's not even about this Nirvana state
of an empty mind, it's actually about more practical
than that in some ways.
It is about being able to navigate thoughts
and see things clearly.
And I think that's a tremendous gift
that is at our disposal right now to work through it.
And I think that kind of work on a personal level
is what's gonna equip all of us
to kind of work our way through.
And yeah, that's what we're seeing in the comment section,
to take it from a spiritual idea
down to like a super absurd example.
But before you might see all comments sort of unified.
But now if you're seeing all these
kinds of disparate voices,
you're seeing like the fragmentation of people
thinking their way through it in the past few weeks.
In 1992 writing was bad or why would these people
burn their own neighborhood?
Well, in Los Angeles, it was an update of '92.
They weren't burning their own neighborhood,
it was like a strategic move to burn
non-black neighborhoods.
The conversation that's happening with white people
about the difference between protesting,
peaceful protesting, looting, and rioting.
That's an interesting conversation to have
instead of just kind of watching your TV screen
glow in the night and kind of like making assumptions
on what you think it is.